people out there a lot of people don't
know I do know but I just want to
clarify it
what does T Fuu actually stand for
nothing
yeah how did you come up with the name
was just a gamertag back in the day
there's no meaning behind it there's no
meaning people think there's I mean
seriously your brother told me it was
Turner [ __ ] up everyone that's what
people think yeah I'm used for letters
back before they like released like I
was like maybe a couple years ago or
three years ago they like deleted all
the inactive Xbox accounts but before
then it was really hard to get like
lower lower lettered gamer tags yeah
so that's TFE I couldn't get any three
letters so I just what was the four I
think you should just go with the Turner
[ __ ] up everyone that's pretty cool I
think it's pretty dope yeah so how how
long ago was that when you created that
like was that when you first got into
like online games or was that when you
were like on Xbox or I was on xbox
you're on xbox called Diddy and halo
okay and that's when you created that
yeah how long ago was that six years ago
[Music]